[Music]
5 25 on your Wednesday morning we do
have a solution to a viewer's email
about a busy intersection in Henderson
Randy's got a lot to say about multiple
crashes at Bermuda and Erie which is
just up the street from Liberty High
School in Henderson he rides with no
traffic signal the intersection's
challenging and confusing for drivers
and pedestrians no crosswalks or
pedestrian signals particularly
dangerous for children in the elderly he
included pictures of a recent crash
there
well Randy the city of Henderson's
Madeleine's Gaines tells me the
intersection of Bermuda Neri is in the
design phase for the installation of a
traffic signal which he says is a
process that can average anywhere
between nine months and a year to
complete
so maybe not as fast as the solution as
you might like Randy but we do think it
sounds like there's change on the way
thanks for writing in and keep us posted
on the progress buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com